[Music]
angela merkel has been german chancellor
for 12 years
and is running for office for the fourth
time ms merkel we're delighted to have
the chance to speak to you here at the
chancellor in
in the german capital
i'm pleased too welcome hello madam
chancellor
almost the entire world knows your face
and your name in these uncertain times
of terror and war and collapsing
alliances
many people are afraid of the future and
place great expectations in you
people often ask us what you are
actually afraid of
i don't think fear is a good advisor we
must face our challenges head on
and we face huge tasks then we can
consider what to do
in my experience when the world works
together we can move mountains
when everyone has different opinions it
can take a really long time to reach
a solution at all but we negotiate talk
and find one is there anything that
keeps you from sleeping at night
well there are situations to which i
have to devote a lot of thought
such as now when i think about the
question of ukraine and russia
when i think about the syrian civil war
which has robbed so many millions of
their homes
or when i think about the nuclear tests
by the north korean dictator
that naturally worries me too but rather
than fearing these problems
i consider how i can solve them
you have been in office for 12 years
doesn't an unlimited number of terms in
office harm pluralism in society
and with that democracy
i don't think so there are different
systems there are direct election
systems where there are usually term
limits
for example the french and american
presidential elections
in germany we elect parties and you
can't limit the number of terms for
parties
and those parties then select their own
top candidates which is why the number
of terms in office is not limited
so in germany for example the number of
terms of office
is limited for the president germany's
head of state
but not for the chancellor
so if i understand you correctly you are
opposed to limiting the period in office
for a chancellor to two terms for
example
as we already said you have been
chancellor for 12 years and have
attended many un general assemblies
what do you think when you hear us
president donald trump threatening north
korea with total destruction
in the event of an attack
i am against threats of this kind and
speaking for myself
and the government i must say that we
consider any type of
military solution absolutely
inappropriate and we are counting on
diplomatic efforts
this must be vigorously implemented in
my opinion sanctions and enforcing these
sanctions
are the right answer but anything else
with regard to north korea i think is
wrong
and that is why we clearly disagree with
the u.s president
[Music]
i did speak with him before his speech a
few days ago
i also made it clear during our phone
conversation that a diplomatic solution
needs to be found
are you offering to act as a mediator
i made it clear that germany is prepared
to assume responsibility
alone or as part of the european union
even if this conflict is far away from
germany it is one that also
affects us that is why i am prepared
as is the foreign minister to assume
responsibility here
we took part in negotiating the iran
agreement which i think is good
and better than having no agreement at
all
it took many years but in the end it did
limit iran's possibilities for nuclear
armament
and i think we must take the same path
or a similar one
with russia with china together with the
us
also in the case of north korea
for north korea would you also ring kim
jong-un
that's not on the agenda now i also do
not intend to take steps which haven't
been agreed upon
that would weaken the international
community of states
but we can't just avoid taking
responsibility either
staying with foreign policy i understand
of course that you have to speak to
governments who do not necessarily
correspond to the level of democracy we
have here
even um
you signed a security agreement with
egypt and according to human rights
watch
the interior ministry with whom you
signed this agreement
has itself been accused of using torture
along with the agreements we sign with
them we also talk about things that
bother us
with egypt for example we've had long
and in part very controversial
discussions about our employees from
political foundations
we talk about human rights abuses and
situations that contravene the rule of
law
yet on one hand foreign policy is always
about looking after our interests
and on the other about safeguarding our
values
and there are many reasons to help egypt
become a stable country
a country that enjoys reasonable
economic development
so there are reasons for us to sign a
joint agreement
but it's also a country that restricts
press freedom and suppresses the
opposition
we from dw for example are censored
therefore
yeah as i've already stated we know
about this from political foundations
and now for example from you from
deutsche welle
and there we clearly tell president
el-sisi that we criticize that that we
don't think it's right
but not to talk to them because
everything isn't just as we would wish
it
or to say we won't negotiate at all with
egypt
i think that's the wrong approach
because
egypt needs our support and through
dialogue we can perhaps take small steps
towards improvement
a major issue that our international
audience also associates you with is the
refugee one
the essential question there is always
how long can refugees stay in germany
what is your plan
the protected status of refugees varies
on the one hand we have refugees who
have been granted the full status
defined by the convention on refugees
they're initially allowed to stay here
for three years
and if after three years the situation
in their homeland hasn't improved
they can get permanent residency status
then there are refugees with subsidiary
protection status
there we look at the situation in their
homeland on a yearly basis and decide
accordingly
so it's dependent on their protected
status
we have people who return home
voluntarily such as to iraq
when cities there have been liberated
from is people also return
and we support these voluntary attorneys
because we want to give the people there
a reasonable chance to start over again
what if the war in syria lasts for 20
years
what will we do then if a family lives
here grew up here the kids go to school
and parents work
well as i said those who have the full
status defined by the convention on
refugees will after a certain time
get permanent residency status with
people who are earning a living and
supporting themselves
we could review their cases however
let's hope the syrian conflict won't
last 20 years
but given the situation in syria the
people who are here at the moment
have no reason to fear being sent back
i have visited many refugee facilities
in germany and spoken with the people in
their own language
many refugees are becoming frustrated
right now they feel abandoned what
precisely do you want to
[Music]
but the good news is we're now down to
only 100 000
unprocessed applications and hundreds of
thousands have already been given a
decision
one way or the other
[Music]
many people don't realize refugees first
have to take a german course
before they can start school or job
training
and that takes time but we do our utmost
to get young people into education
and even those without a full residence
permit can work
or
nevertheless many see german bureaucracy
as being very slow
and would like to be able to enter the
labor market much faster
but we cannot allow that either because
we cannot allow destructive competition
that perhaps germans who are seeking
employment cannot find certain jobs
we have to keep on finding a balance
there
germany is an orderly country but that
means things may take a little longer
and i can only ask for patience
i'd like to focus on another group that
has been living in germany for a long
time
people of turkish origin we keep hearing
that many of them still feel the
question as to where they actually
belong hasn't been answered
could this perhaps also be due to the
fact that your party still doesn't
accept that germany is an immigration
country
we have long since said goodbye to the
times when we called
these people guest workers everyone is
able to acquire german citizenship
that means people with turkish roots can
become just as german as those whose
families may have lived here for
centuries
i always tell people who've been here a
long time but
might not have german citizenship that
they have contributed to the prosperity
of our country
and therefore belong here if they obey
the law
of course what worries us is the fact
that different groups from turkey
are maybe spying on or surveilling each
other
[Music]
how exactly do you want to do that or
make sure that
precisely that doesn't happen
by investigating every case by really
encouraging people who feel they are
being watched
to inform us and then taking decisive
action against the respective sources
or those doing that
almost all of your coalition partners
want a real immigration law
i'm not talking about the law regulating
the immigration of skilled workers
but about a real immigration law is that
something you are willing to negotiate
i believe that our proposed law on
skilled workers is exactly what others
might describe
as an immigration law we say that our
country
needs to bring in skilled workers we
have a shortage of specialists
and the european union's blue card
scheme offers us very good options for
immigration
especially for high earners with
academic degrees
and i think that is the right thing to
do because we do not want immigrants to
end up in our welfare system
the details have to be negotiated we
know for example that canada has
long preferred a point-based system but
is now also looking at the question
what jobs do we actually want to fill it
needs to be said that immigration laws
are always aimed to serve the needs of
the country
into which people come
by contrast asylum law the refugee
convention
is a humanitarian obligation that is not
tied to a workplace
and these are two separate issues
and that is why we've made our position
clear by naming it the law regulating
the immigration of skilled workers
madam chancellor germany is voting this
sunday according to current polls the
afd could become the third
strongest party in the bundestag why
haven't you been able to prevent this
it is i do not wish to speculate about
the outcome of the election as you can
understand
but i will call on as many people as
possible to support what we in the cdu
and csu are offering with their
our two votes have had certain
disagreements especially about the euro
and its stabilization also on refugee
policy
i believe these were fundamental
decisions for europe for the single
currency
and for our humanitarian commitments
they've naturally also provoked
discussions throughout society
some of them heeded but i think these
decisions were both correct and
necessary and that is why we must try to
solve the problems that are connected to
it
to earn people's trust and let them know
that every vote counts
but in certain situations fundamental
decisions like these have to be made is
germany's international broadcaster
many people keep asking us germany is so
well off
you have good schools you have decent
health care and a good retirement
program
despite all this the afd this populist
right-wing party is so successful
can you try to explain this to our
international viewers
i don't want to explain this because i
will never work with the afd
but i just want to say that there are
indeed people in germany who have
problems
this does not justify certain political
attitudes or
exclusion but we must also work very
hard to ensure that we have equal living
conditions
we have rural areas where internet
access is slow to arrive
in which there is a shortage of doctors
we have people who've worked for many
years and still have a very small
pension
and that is why even though our country
ranks highly by international standards
here too many people have to struggle to
make ends meet
another question about the afd according
to polls
some voters who up to now have voted for
the cdu
or csu are migrating to the afd
do you have an idea on how to win these
voters
the worries they have having their own
jobs as well as decent schools and
doctors
to really take care of these issues but
on the other hand to signal a clear stop
to hatred and violence
thank you very much to finish we always
like to ask the same question
imagine you had to spend one month on a
desert island and could only survive if
you took one of these people with you
one of the other party lead candidates
and you need to choose one of these
people or you won't survive
i'd take joachim herman cdu
i would discuss with him how we can
improve internal security in germany
and perhaps he would ask me a few policy
issues that he hasn't dealt with yet
thank you very much you're welcome
could you pass me the mobile phone
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
this is the town of bitterfelt in
eastern germany
annette gammon the woman with the red
ponytail considers mackel an enemy
she wants to throw her out of office
he's done nothing for germans just
foreign
is a stronghold of the right-wing
populist afd party
[Applause]
many local residents don't like the
chancellor or her government
and they make that clear when she
arrives for her speech
many refugees came to germany in 2015.
there was a humanitarian emergency
[Applause]
[Music]
i would like to thank all the local
politicians
the volunteers the churches and ngos
and associations for all they did to
help people
the crowd reaction is mixed some
obviously disagree with the chancellor
many of the refugees are following the
election campaign closely
[Applause]
ramadafsha and his friends arrived from
afghanistan in 2015.
they don't understand why the afd
supporters are so upset
some of them don't have jobs or money so
they complain about mrs marco
but that's wrong in germany everyone can
work
get training and find a good job
the chancellor makes a low profile
departure
she'd just as soon avoid this crowd
[Music]
this is the city of ludwigsoffen in
southwestern germany
some cdu supporters are also opposed to
mackel's refugee policy
i'm really concerned i want my country
to be safer i want secure borders
so we know who we're letting in a year
ago mackel's poll numbers were down
many blamed her for a series of
terrorist attacks
but she managed to regain much of her
popularity
still there are some here who are not
pleased with the chancellor
they're shouting get out and mackel must
go
[Applause]
of course islamist terrorism poses a
huge
challenge
[Applause]
only face the challenge by working
together
and by working with the european union
europe is important for our security
both at home and abroad is by no means a
nationalist but she does
understand the concepts of german
homeland prosperity and security
tarak and lana al-murabet arrived from
syria in 2016
after their homeland prosperity and
security were destroyed in the civil war
to see this wonderful woman is like a
dream come true for me
i can't describe it
after the chancellor has left the stage
one of her staffers
poses for a few selfies she also plays
down the role of the right-wing hecklers
these people always travel around with
the afd that is part of our democracy
but it doesn't speak very well for our
country in a democracy
it's important to listen to others you
can be critical but always treat others
with respect
nuremberg in southern germany the cdu
csu's pro-business wing is meeting at
the convention center
they've been some of mackel's most
outspoken critics in recent years
and they've often contradicted her in
public
a year ago the chancellor would have
felt like she was walking into a lion's
den
but the internal party criticism has
died down
here markle focuses on economic
successes and the digital future
not refugees
sorry 12 years ago no one had a
smartphone
used to sign autographs there were no
selfies
things have
we have to remember to talk to each
other and not focus on communicating
with someone on the other side of the
world
angela merkel has managed to turn her
campaign around and she's done it
quietly too
even her critics including karsten
linderman admit
that she has changed things for the
better
[Applause]
there is now some consensus the
chancellor herself says that there can
be no repeat of 2015.
everyone has to work towards successful
integration because people are coming to
us from very different cultures
there's very clear agreement on that
and then it's on to the next stop
berlin the day of the tv debate between
the two top candidates for chancellor
it's the first time the two candidates
are squaring off against each other
the spd's martin schultz is far behind
in the polls
the debate could help him to improve his
ratings
[Applause]
and the debate is underway marco
presents herself as an indispensable
crisis manager
but the moderator challenges her on her
apparent attempts to try to be
all things to all people
i think that people change in the course
of their lives but the challenges that
they face are always new
in an interview mrs merkel said that she
would do what she did in 2015
again if she had to i would not
recommend that
we made the mistake of not involving our
european partners
we presented them with a done deal and
this means that today the hungarian and
polish leaders are shirking their
responsibilities
after the debate mackel met some of her
more enthusiastic supporters
the post debate polls indicate that most
germans think that markle will be
re-elected
a lot of voters seem to have calmed down
now